beware of the hot dogs not sure where
they're from
how can you get something for free well
it's free if you don't get caught you
can get free movie passes
pretty much if you about anything enough
they have these uh guest services desk
if you go up and you're just like it was
too cold or
it was so loud for your movie passes so
just
the real trick if you get something for
free honestly is just flirt with us tell
us what we want to hear what we want to
know there's one guy i know girl just
flirts with just a tiny bit he gets them
whatever they want all this food drinks
candy for free
what's the most wild thing that you saw
in the movie theater i was ushering one
day and this woman came out and said
that there was some funny business going
on in the back of the theater
no [ __ ] that's where all the funny
business goes on and there were two high
schoolers uh getting down and i had to
shine the light and be like my guys you
need to leave right now and it was so
awkward i was actually taking out the
trash and i heard like a moaning sound
like the movie is closed there's no
reason his last movie and i look up and
these people are having sex in the movie
theater when i heard the morning i was
like hey and you're like they got just
dude they just left like so fast i found
like a thing of lube in um the theater
when i was cleaning up and i wanted to
be like you should just get some of that
movie theater butter because it's
straight oil it'll do the same job and
it tastes real good so
what happens if you get caught movie
hopping honestly we really don't care
unless it's like a huge movie premiere
like it's sold out like the avengers
type movie we're not standing in front
of the doors like checking every ticket
just kind of like walk around like you
own the place like yeah i'm gonna bounce
from movie to movie and you're not gonna
tell me
but some employees are really strict and
they will literally ban you or they will
let you make you leave some of them will
even call the cops it's not even that
deep what is the best seat in a movie
theater i'd say like in the middle so
that way you're not like you know don't
have your head arched up the dead center
that's where the sound quality is the
best in the rows between the middle and
the last row this is the middle and this
is the back i would say like somewhere
here it's not so cramped it's not so
crowded if there's an empty theater
don't sit next to someone that's weird
find your own space
we never see the theater with the lights
on how dirty is it
you have like less than five minutes to
clean in between films so most of the
time we just like
sweep trash under the seats and hope no
one really notices god knows when last
time those chairs were like actually
cleaned
i never saw them clean those seats
there's a good chance he probably sat in
a chair where some old dude probably
just
urinated on himself because i had to
help a dude out of this chair to make
sure he did not do that
so
yeah so as you're getting all
comfortable curling up into the seat
just think of all the bodily fluids that
are on there and dirt and trash and it's
crazy you find money in the movie
theaters too we actually do not always
return them we're supposed to
well we take it i'll just grab that do
employees care if you bring in outside
snacks if you keep it in your bag nobody
[ __ ] cares i don't care maybe jake
and antoine don't care but margaret
cares because she loves the manager and
she sucks ass so yes she cares and she
won't let you go anywhere because you
bringing snacks i've seen people
bringing a whole box of pizza ones and
i'm like
there was a guy that had like two
shopping bags coming in like he had gone
to the grocery store and was like he had
like alcohol all this stuff and because
i was the worst employee ever i was just
like yo can i have a beer after one time
when i was cleaning i actually found a
kfc box so they were going in
finger looking good let's talk about the
butter i remember this girl came up to
me and said could i just get plain
popcorn please i'm vegan so i can't have
butter and i want to be like girl you
could have as much of that butter as you
want because there is no dairy in that
it's not real butter it's like an oil
with some type of um i don't even know
it's like artificial oil you know that i
can't believe it's not butter it's like
that like it's mad fake if you saw the
big tins of oil and the little powder
flavor thing we use it would turn you
off but whatever it's still good you
have to eat it a little bit of it what's
the most annoying part of the job
cleaning toilets is probably the worst
part of the job
because eating all that nacho cheese and
popcorn like
i've had to clean up feces off the floor
it was literally like
right at the base of the toilet i'm like
how did you miss best day or time to go
to the movies definitely during the week
monday through wednesday morning or
early afternoon because if you go in the
morning you get matinee
showings which
are cheaper tickets
the fastest way to get kicked out of
movie theater is if your phone's going
off they don't play that at all not even
a little bit
not even a little bit they don't play
that and people like shut up stop
talking stop talking like you get so mad
you know when your foes go up stop
yelling people will come out and they'll
come to us and they'll be like
this guy right over here doing this one
thing he keeps doing it all movie and
we're like
we'll have to go in and if they're not
gonna work with us you're out they bang
you for everything no reason you breathe
the wrong way band you talk the one way
bad your phone goes off bad they just
ban you for no reason it's sick
[Music]
you